it's me breaking news so yes if you
didn't hear apparently there was
actually at the time of recording last I
checked it hadn't closed yet it was on
the verge of doing so that might it
might have closed or might have fallen
apart by the time I get this video out
we'll see but Nintendo is closing a deal
to give movie rights to illumination
animation for Super Mario Brothers which
means the Mario movie that nobody really
was asking for after the last one we got
um could very well end up being they
have probably animated this time which I
think after have a live-action version
when most people are favoring that I'm a
little less sure about what to think
about this this news for a couple of
reasons I mean the first is illumination
is not a bad animation studio but I look
at their track record and it's
Despicable Me minions Secret Life of
pets there are a couple of movies they
made that are genuinely bad some of them
that's not all of them it's not even the
majority of them but like at least to my
way of thinking their movies have topped
out at being fine
no that was fine a couple good moments
that was fine and I kind of wish there
was somebody with if not a stronger
track record at least like a single like
really good movie that could point to
well they did that one that one time so
maybe we can maybe we can get that level
of Mario and I don't feel like
illumination has that I mean heck even
sky blue studios the Ice Age people even
they have you know the peanuts movie
which is genuinely really really good so
I mean that's the only thing on their
lineup that's really good but even they
have one thing so
I I it's hard for me to get excited with
this animation studio and to steal a
line from Bob Shipman now that is paired
with the studio's place your bets is it
going to be the shy guys the Yoshi's are
the toads that are going to be Mario's
answer to the minions
yeah I mean I have to imagine that if
they wanted to go animated Nintendo was
in a bit of a I don't want to say tight
spot but their options probably weren't
what they would like to have been Disney
was probably never an option because
Disney these days if they think Disney
doesn't really like to license things
anymore they like to own them so unless
Disney steps up to buying intend to lock
stock and barrel which I don't want them
to ever do then I I don't see that ever
having happened
I mean maybe Sony animation might have
been a better place for them to land in
terms of their track record cuz you know
they gave us things like Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs which was really
good but of course Sony they owned the
PlayStation and that is one of
Nintendo's rivals so they were probably
out I mentioned sky sky blue I mean you
know he despite even the early
comparison that I made sky blue really
the only reason the penis movie turned
out as good as it did is because the the
Schultz family were really hands on and
making sure that that honored the legacy
of Charles Schulz's work so unless
Nintendo's prepared to dig into that
level which they might be because I
think I had heard before that part of
the reason Nintendo was so sad mean
aside from kind of really being badly
burned by the first Super Mario Brothers
movie part of the reason they were slow
to get things going was they wanted a
fairly decent amount of input on the
process and that sounds good except that
Ubisoft had a pretty good level of
influence on the Assassin's Creed film
and the thing is they may know the
characters of the property but they're
not filmmakers they don't the the
dictation zuv video game makers may not
be a good thing to have when someone's
trying to craft a movie now I mean I I'm
totally fine with them being like no
like that that idea is way too awful we
want to do but I really hope they're not
gonna try and dictate structure story
arcs character or inventin that they'll
even allow them to do character arcs and
possibly do something a little
unexpected with them because otherwise
I think we just end up with basically an
extended cutscene I mean the the I mean
I've talked about this with video image
before I think the inherent problem with
the vast majority of video game
properties is their stories and
characters are not built for film
they're not built to be observed they're
built to be played and and that's why so
many of these characters are especially
the iconic ones are pretty thinly
sketched out you don't need a ton of
depth to really get into them because
you're controlling them directly and
that does create a bond between player
and player avatar and removing that a
lot of these characters they're really
thinly sketched out knowing how
defensive Nintendo is probably gonna be
about the characterizations I have to
wonder if they're gonna allow a studio
to sort of do what you'd have to do with
the character to give them an art give
them a journey make them interesting of
course I say that the other problem with
it doing animation as opposed to
live-action uh note this is not me
saying they should do a live-action
movie but there's a tendency by oh not
all animation studios but a fair number
of them that when they make something
that is blatantly for kids but they
don't try as hard they're more willing
to dip into clichés and stereotypes and
tropes because they figure they can get
away with it
because the audience is kids kids don't
care and that's always a shame and it's
why like the really great animated
movies I'll always have a special place
in my heart
you know classics and new ones because
anyone who looks at animation and
doesn't go oh you know it's kid stuff we
don't have to try our but instead goes
you know what let's try a harder let's
give really quality entertainment to
people at an early age that I will
always admire that but I just I look at
this lineup this pairing and I can't say
I'm thrilled I'm not I'm not going it's
going to stink I don't think it will I
just I think it'll probably be fine and
functional and basically a cash-in on
Mario an attempt to expand things now
that said I do hope it actually succeeds
mainly because there are other Nintendo
properties that I
like to see adapted to film much more
than Mario I mean the thing with me and
Mario at this point is I have a
nostalgic grab onto Mario I mean I I
haven't / it's oh it's behind the the
Kurds against humanity but iíve got a
original NES so you know I and still I
grew up on it and our grew up on Mario I
love this stuff but I don't really have
a dog in this race in this boy I still
enjoy playing Mario games but I don't
have you know a real all beloved
character feeling - Mario add as a
character when I am NOT controlling him
there are other characters and other
stories though that I think are begging
for at least somebody to try and see
what they can do I know a lot of people
are gonna say Zelda and I mean as far as
size of properties that Nintendo has
that's probably the next one in the list
I actually I don't think it is gonna be
that good and I'm sure I'm gonna get a
lot of hate just for even suggesting
that but look here's the thing about
Zelda is Zelda is ultimately a pretty
generic fantasy world and fantasy story
and I'm not saying that as a knock on
the games I love the Zelda games but the
fact that it's generic is fine in the
game because you are getting to
experience it you were getting to
getting to experience the depth of this
but it is ultimately still a fairly
generic world in a fairly generic story
I mean there are very like elf forest
people there are the fish people live in
the water there are the kind of rock
people live in the mountains there's the
prophesied hero on a chosen one journey
to rescue a princess and get a magic
weapon and kill them I mean it's
incredibly generic and in a game that's
fine cuz you get to play that you get to
experience that in a way having it be
more generic is almost to its benefit as
opposed to having to go really off the
rails and be really unique in terms of
characterization a story moving because
you get to feel like you are on that
epic quest and having it painted in
those broad strokes works you actually
translate that to Fellman I don't know
what there is to do with it other than
just have the novelty
of oh this time the hero is linked and
you know they'll have to cast an actor
and give them a voice and fanboys
everywhere will hate it for whatever
reason cuz that's what will happen the
property that I want to see the Nintendo
property I think just is begging for
somebody you take a crack at it is
Metroid oh the world needs Samus Aran
right now so I mean I still feel like in
many ways we have yet to get a true
proper successor to Ellen Ripley or
Sarah Connor that like real kick ass
sci-fi heroine I feel like we haven't
had that really to sort of step up well
I'm not to say that we haven't had good
heroines had some great ones not to say
there haven't even been good ones in
sci-fi movies there have been but I mean
I feel like nobody's really taken that
torch yet and I think Samus could as
long as they don't do other M version of
samus no but that's the one I'd really
like to see and I basically I I don't
have a heavy stick in the Mario movie if
it's good great if it's not okay but I
kind of hope it succeeds either way
because I don't want a Nintendo to get
scared off again because I I would like
to see these something done with these
properties now I don't I don't think
everything works for films some things
would be better for TV series like if
you are gonna do Zelda TV would be a
much better fit for it than a movie I
think but I would like to see these
things expended cuz as much as i rail
against the fact that i do honestly
think trying to translate a video game
into movies is fundamentally a flawed
idea it's something that they're gonna
keep trying until somebody makes it work
and if somebody's gonna make it work I
kind of like to see it being Nintendo so
yeah I think I've rambled enough on all
that so those are my thoughts on the
news that there's probably gonna be an
animated Super Mario Brothers movie what
are your thoughts on it what other than
I know properties do you think should
get a movie or TV treatment whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that's available on iTunes and stitcher
I'm also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast that's a presentation of
the fire and water podcast network fired
martyr podcast calm and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]